you
the
hey guys it's Joanna here it's the
Chinese New Year don't see fat chai I
love this time of the year because I get
to go back and see all my family members
and also catch up with my childhood
friends and of course not forgetting the
food and cookies and the kisses Chinese
New Year I want to introduce to you
three super foods which are very
commonly used in Asian cuisine they are
also very well known for their
therapeutic and healing properties in
traditional Chinese medicine as well as
I use Vedic medicine lemongrass ginger
and turmeric so lemongrass has a very
distinct lemon and citrusy flavor ginger
has a very warm and spicy taste it is
slightly sweet but very pungent turmeric
is also known as the queen of spices
it has a pepper like aroma shop taste
and golden in color it is vast known as
one of the key ingredients to make a
delicious curry so I want to share with
you three Asian detox tea as well as
steam inhalation therapy to help detox
of a mind and guys if you haven't know
it I have been collaborating with the
National Academy of Sports Medicine &
ASM to offer you guys at the opportunity
to become a personal trainer so if you
are passionate about helping others to
get healthy if you really want to live a
healthy lifestyle yourself then do check
out their online personal training
course a 14-day free trial okay you can
learn more about nutrition fitness
understand your clients as well as steps
on becoming a successful personal
trainer be sure to click on the link in
my description box and get more
information so guys I trust that you
probably already have all these three
ingredients in your kitchen and so
before we make these herbal teas here
are 10 reasons why you should drink them
on a regular basis so these hubbell teas
are known to cleanse and detoxify the
body because of their diuretic
properties they can help to cleanse and
flush out all the harmful toxins in our
body so I like to enjoy this horrible
teas especially of
a series of overindulgence or eating bad
food while Chinese New Year can be that
time of the year the second reason is
that these teas are also easy on the
stomach and ate improper digestion so if
you do experience constipation diarrhea
bloating or gas drinking them on a
regular basis can help to improve your
digestive system well if you don't have
a healthy and good digestive system your
body will not be able to absorb all the
nutrients and vitamins from the food you
eat and as a result it can hinder your
weight loss which then lead on to my
next point
a healthy digestive system can help to
speed up weight loss these herbs and
spices can help to boost the metabolism
egg as a fat burner and prevent the
accumulation of fat especially around
the abdominal area they can also make
you feel fuller for much longer which
prevent overeating and when it comes to
detoxifying the mind
these Hubbell teas are known to have a
calming effect because of its strong
aroma and healing properties so when I
go for my monthly facial session they
would invite us to inhale the aroma of
lemongrass as a way to relax the body
and mind and right at the end of the
session if they would serve us with a
cup of lemongrass and ginger tea just to
you know relax the mind and also body so
there is a reason why when you step into
a spa it is usually filled with the
aroma of lemongrass because it will make
you feel come quite instantly in the
space and of course when you detox the
mind and body you will naturally have a
more beautiful and youthful skin if
you're someone who suffers from insomnia
or lack of energy drinking huh booty
right before your bedtime can help to
relax your muscles and nerves and help
to improve the quality of your sleep you
can also drink them first thing in the
morning to get the blood in your body
flowing and help to boost your energy
level when I was in London I used to
live with a housemaid
would start his day every morning by
drinking ginger and lemon juice and
trust me I have seen the benefit on his
body and energy level so if you take
them on a regular basis it can help to
relieve inflamed joints and also reduce
muscle soreness especially after
exercising so if you're someone that's
really active if you do a lot of
workouts be sure to include these T's
into your daily routine to help your
muscles to recover better and talking
about my housemate in London back then
whenever I show any sign of coal or flu
he would force me to drink his ginger
and lemon tea although at that time I
absolutely hated the taste of ginger
these teas are traditionally known as
home remedies to help relieve congestion
so these superfoods are also packed with
powerful antioxidants that can help to
strengthen your immunity and fight
cancer causing free radicals I do know
of some people who would drink them on a
regular basis to prevent cancer
especially if they know that their
family has a history of cancer and
finally for ladies if you do experience
menstrual discomfort drinking this tea
can help to relieve cramps and bloating
and besides that you can also take a
towel and soak them into ginger tea and
apply them to your lower abdomen this
can actually help to relax the muscle
and relieve the pain so now that you
know all the health benefits and why we
agents like to drink herbal teas you
should also try them and make them it is
really simple
so for lemongrass tea just add 4 cups of
water and about 3 lemongrass stocks for
turmeric tea again 4 cups of water to 1
teaspoon of turmeric and ginger tea 4
cups of water and 1 tablespoon of grated
ginger all you need to do is add the
combination into a pot of boiling water
then reduce the heat and simmer for
about 15 to 20 minutes
to release the flavor and healing
properties and it's done you can choose
to sweeten it with a little bit of raw
honey maple syrup or rock sugar and if
you think that the taste is slightly too
strong to your liking you can also add a
squeeze of lemon juice to mask its taste
so to gain the full benefits remember to
drink 2 to 3 cups
throughout the day and one final tip is
that remember to pound the lemon grass
or crush the ginger to release the
flavor during cooking and other huble
teas combination include lemongrass and
ginger ginger and turmeric lemongrass
and turmeric or lemongrass ginger and
turmeric so besides drinking another
great way to gain the health properties
is through steam inhalation therapy so
grab a large bowl you know you can
choose to use ginger lemongrass or
tumeric I like to go with lemongrass
because I love the aroma of lemongrass
place it in a bowl ok and grab a pot of
boiling hot water and just pour it into
the large bowl ok and you can see that
the steam will just help to release the
aroma of the lemongrass ok make sure
that it is full then all you have to do
is grab a large towel ok cover yourself
lean over and just inhale the steam for
5 to 10 minutes
I love the aroma of lemongrass this acts
as a natural mood lifter it helps to
reduce stress it helps with depression
and also help with common cold or flu it
also helps to moisturize the skin
cleanse the poor and improve our skin
appearance ah that felt so good
you know this steam inhalation therapy
has helped to improve my mood and also
help with my skin break out especially
due to the hot weather so guys I would
recommend you to you know drink this
humble tea on a regular basis and also
try the steam inhalation therapy trust
me you will feel so good and you would
want to do it on a regular basis so try
it out let me know which is your
favourite Hubble combination in the
comments below all the best
the
you